ce mandat d'élu local est la plus belle
des responsabilités les parisiennes et
les parisiens auront au cours des six
années qui viennent besoin de nous avec
mon équipe nous serons là je suis
particulièrement ému ce soir je pense
bien sûr à toutes celles et ceux qui
m'ont permis de devenir la femme que je
suis je pense à ceux qui m'ont inspiré
je pense aux parisiennes et aux
parisiens qui m'ont toujours soutenu
je pense à mes amis à ma famille je
pense à mon père arrivé en france avec
la république en idéal et qui voulait
que ses filles le réalise
je crois qu'il serait heureux
aujourd'hui fier que sa fille à son tour
porte l'idéal républicain pour
l'ensemble des parisiennes et des
parisiens
[Applaudissements]